SIERRA: If you travel often, you’ve probably
used a lot of different currencies.
Pesos, yen, pounds and euros.
But there is one currency that is desirable
pretty much anywhere you go - the U.S. dollar.
Dollars have a near universal value, and in
a pinch, a vendor in a New Dehli market or
a waiter in Spain will likely accept one as
payment.
But behind the scenes the dollar is playing
another, more important global role, one that
many of us find confusing.
It’s a reserve currency.
For almost a century, countries have been
buying dollars as a kind of insurance policy.
As a result, around $6.7 trillion U.S. dollars
are held in reserve around the world.
The fact that the dollar is the world’s
main reserve currency has given the United
States significant economic power.
It allows the United States to borrow easily,
to recover quickly from economic shocks, and
to impose sanctions on adversaries.
But power like that comes with some drawbacks,
and there is no guarantee that the dollar
will keep its status forever.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters.
Today how the U.S. dollar shapes the world,
and what that means for Americans.
CBS This Morning: The Federal Reserve is taking
sweeping action to try to protect the economy
from the coronavirus.
Fed chairman Jerome Powell announced the interest
rate will be drastically cut in one of the
biggest Fed moves since the 2008 financial
crisis.
ABC World News: China has a huge invested
interest in the American economy because it
holds almost 25 percent of all foreign-owned
U.S. debts.
DW News: U.S. sanctions against Iran over
its nuclear program were reintroduced...
Iran’s economy in a free fall, soaring inflation.
Al Jazeera: If push comes to shove, it’s
all..
It's the world reserve currency.
SIERRA: So to start off, what is a reserve
currency and why does it matter?
MALLABY: So, Gabby, I think the first thing
is to explain what a currency is before we
get to reserve currency.
SIERRA: This is Sebastian Mallaby, a senior
fellow for international economics at the
Council.
You may remember him from our episode on the
economic side of the COVID pandemic.
MALLABY: A currency has a few different uses.
One is that it's a unit of account.
It's a way of putting a measure on what something
might be worth.
The second is, once you've decided what it's
worth, that you should be able to transact.
So transactions are the second idea that you
can go off and buy stuff, with the currency.
And a third idea, is that you can use money
as a store of value.
Before you transact, you can save up this
currency, and then transact in the future.
SIERRA: So for those keeping track at home,
money does three basic things.
It lets us agree on prices, it lets us buy
things, and it lets us save up so we can buy
other things later.
Now, the same three things that currency does
for people, reserve currencies do for entire
countries: pricing, buying, and saving.
MALLABY: So literally, a reserve currency
is the currency you hold in reserves.
So it's very linked to the last idea I mentioned
of the store of value and in particular, we
think of reserve banks,I mean, central banks,
global central banks, which hold, currencies
and reserve to protect their economies against
various kinds of financial or economic shock.
So a reserve currency really has a couple
of different functions.
One is to cover the need for future imports.
If a country, for example, doesn't have its
own energy supply, needs to import oil, you
might want to hold dollars in reserve to make
sure that you can buy the oil you need in
the future.
The second reason central banks hold foreign
currency reserves is because of the possibility
of a financial crisis.
And there again,dollars are very useful because
most institutions borrow in dollars.
So in a financial crisis, they're going to
need dollars to help them pay back what they
owe.
SIERRA: Central banks have the unique power
to print money, but in many other ways they
are kinda like a scaled-up version of an ordinary
bank.
Your local bank needs to have enough money
to lend to people if they want to buy a home,
or if things get bad and they need to take
some out.
A central bank needs to be able to do this
too, but for an entire country.
In order to be prepared for the future, they
need to store up a significant amount of cash
that they can trust.
Foreign currencies are often a safer bet than
the local currency, especially in countries
with weak or unstable economies.
The safest bet of all is...the U.S. dollar.
SIERRA: What role does the US dollar serve
in the global reserve system?
FERGUSON: Well, the U.S. dollar now is the
largest single reserve currency.
Economists estimate that approximately 60
percent of foreign reserves around the world
are in US dollars.
SIERRA: This is Roger Ferguson.
He is the President and CEO of TIAA, which
manages over $1 trillion in retirement funds
for more than 5 million teachers, government
workers and, well, me it turns out.
Roger was also Vice Chairman of the Board
of Governors of the Federal Reserve from 1999
to 2006.
This means he helped determine the supply
of U.S. dollars to the country, and the world.
FERGUSON: The euro is about 20 percent the
yen, the Japanese currency is about 5 or 6
percent the British pound also, about 5 or
6 percent.
And so the US, by far away, is the most important
reserve currency but it's not the only currency
that's held in reserve by other economies.
The Chinese, I think, would like to see their
currency, the renminbi, become a larger currency
in terms of its holdings as a reserve currency
around the world.
And yet, you know, in terms of reserves, they
are number four, number five when the list
had only about 2 percent.
SIERRA: I can definitely remember going to
Europe at a time when the Euro was way up
and my money didn't go as far.
And you're just like, "Damn, I, I timed (laughs)
this really poorly," Are other countries literally
buying dollars?
The way that I exchange currency when I visit
a country and where do they buy them from?
MALLABY: It's not quite the same because they're
not collecting lots of $5 bills to put into
the wallet in their belt.
SIERRA: Right.
MALLABY: They’re holding huge amounts.
And so they, what they do is they own US treasury
bonds or other kinds of easily traded dollar-
denominated bonds.
And that could be mortgage bonds as well.
But you know, US government debt is the most
popular instrument to hold.
SIERRA: And how do US treasury bonds work?
MALLABY: Well, the government in the United
Stated wants to borrow money to finance the
U.S. government deficit.
So, the treasury sells these bonds, which
are promises to pay back in ten or thirty
years, or however long the duration of the
bond is.
And those bonds are sold in U.S. capital markets
and anybody can buy these bonds and hold the
bonds either in a sort of custodial bank in
America or in another country.
SIERRA: A treasury bond is essentially a loan
to the U.S. government.
The agreement is that you will get your money
back with interest in a set time.
The returns aren’t very high, but they are
considered one of the safest possible investments
in the world.
And that safety has led to them being held
more often than all other government bonds
in the world combined.
But it hasn’t always been that way.
SIERRA: So how did the U.S. dollar earn its
place as the world's reserve currency or the
biggest, I guess, most prominent reserve currency?
FERGUSON: All of this started at the very
end of the Second World War, when in fact,
we were much more dominant and the world's
economies needed a reserve currency that they
could all trust.
They didn't want to use the gold standard
anymore for a variety of reasons.
And so, you know, 44 countries got together
here in the United States and said, we are
going to anoint the U.S. dollar as a reserve
currency and we are going fix the value of
our currencies to the U.S. dollar.
And so it's a real reflection of the fact
that at the end of the Second World War, the
world needed the U.S. dollar as a reserve
currency and that has continued now, since
1944 to this very day.
SIERRA: Hmm.
And the dollar is a lot lighter to carry around
in your pocket, you know, from like a gold
bar.
FERGUSON: Than an ounce of gold.
Yes, it is.1944 Bretton Woods International
Monetary Conference: At Bretton Woods, New
Hampshire, delegates from 44 allies and associate
countries arrived for the opening of the United
Nations’ monetary and financial conference.
Invited by President Roosevelt, for the first
major world financial meeting since the London
conference in 1933, they will work in the
seclusion of this white mountain resort.
IMF: The fund is essential for winning and
preserving peace.
That is why the representatives are taking
steps to prevent a repetition of the currency
chaos which is usually followed in the wake
of war.
SIERRA: And what helps us maintain this position
now?
MALLABY: I think the first thing to understand
is that there are very strong network effects
with the dollar.
In other words, the more people use the dollar,
the more other people would also like to use
the dollar as well.
It's a little bit like the English language,
the more people around the world who speak
English, the more it's worth your while to
go take English lessons, if you are a pupil
at a high school in Indonesia.
And so it's almost the case that, you know,
the dollar status isn't simply linked to what's
going on inside the United States.
It's also linked to the fact that people in
other countries, whether it's in Latin America
or in Asia, or where have you, are happy to
think in dollars, transact in dollars, borrow
in dollars, use dollar capital markets.
All of that stuff is an incredibly powerful
network effect.
SIERRA: Network effects are fascinating.
So think of social media platforms, for example.
You may not like Facebook or Instagram, personally,
but you may still feel an incentive to remain
on them because all your friends and family
are there too.
If you delete your account, you won’t see
their pictures, and they won’t see yours.
Everyone else uses them, and that keeps you
on, and new users coming in.
In part, dollars retain their value because
everyone else expects them to.
A company, or a country, that decided to ignore
the dollar would find itself out in the cold.
Still, network effects are not the only factor.
FERGUSON: So, the United States doesn't just
have the impression of power.
It is actually the largest single economy
in the world.
And so, you know, power resides where the
economy itself resides, so to speak.
And the United States is the engine of growth
globally, well, along with China and a few
others.
And so, you know, it's not just the impression
that people think we are powerful; we actually
are powerful because we do have the world's
largest economy.
We're also powerful because so many transactions
are denominated in dollars, about half the
world's trade.
And so, if the United States decided, for
example,to put sanctions on an economy or
not allow them to have bank accounts in the
United States or freeze those bank accounts,
it can have a very detrimental impact on that
other economy.
And so there is a reason that people worry
about U.S. sanctions, and the reason is that
we are a powerful country, and not just simply
the appearance of power, but there's an actuality
of power underneath it as well.
MALLABY: I think even more important is the
credibility of the legal system, the independence
of the courts, the sense that if you are a
foreigner and you buy a U.S. bond, it's not
as though a U.S. court will say, " you don't
deserve to be paid back".
Another very important thing is whether the
United States avoids inflation.
Obviously, if you are lending money in dollars,
you're going to be paid back with future dollars.
And if there's future dollars that devalued
by inflation, you won't be happy with that.
So I think a credible independent Federal
Reserve is extremely important to the status
of the dollar as a reserve currency.
SIERRA: The Federal Reserve has a lot of leeway,
and does a very good job of keeping the dollar
safe and stable.
They have the power to increase and decrease
the supply of dollars, even when the public
or a sitting president do not want them to.
As a result of this independence, transactions
in dollars are seen as the safest around.
Take a country like Argentina, which has had
huge fluctuations in the value of its currency
over the years.
Let’s say Argentina wants to borrow 10,000
pesos from you.
And you love Argentina, so you decide to do
it.
There’s just one problem, what will those
10,000 pesos be worth when Argentina gives
them back?
In 2001 that might have been enough to buy
a car, but a decade earlier, during one of
the country’s financial crises, it would
have been worth a whole lot less.
There’s an easy solution.
Ask Argentina to price the loan in dollars
instead.
Now you can be confident you’ll be getting
the same amount of money back.
This plays out all over the world, all the
time, whether for loans, barrels of oil, or
shipping containers full of TVs.
And all of that trading and saving in U.S.
dollars has an enormous effect on the U.S.
economy at home.
SIERRA: So let's look at what our reserve
status does for our own economy.
What are the good sides?
MALLABY: Well, the good sides are that the
U.S. dollar will be stronger than it would
otherwise be.
And so U.S. citizens who have dollars and
get paid in dollars can go on vacation in
Europe, and it would be cheaper than it might
otherwise have been, notwithstanding your
own ,Gabby,and your poor timing.
MALLABY: Try it again, come to Europe another
time-
SIERRA: Yeah.
MALLABY:...
you'll, you'll have a nice vacation.
So, U.S. citizens get to go abroad on vacation
a bit more cheaply.
They can also buy imports from stores in the
United Stated a bit cheaper than they would
otherwise have been, if the dollar had been
weaker.
SIERRA: That last one is a biggie.
As much as American politicians like to insist
on the importance of restoring American manufacturing,
Americans really, really like to buy cheap
foreign goods.
When you go to Best Buy, you expect to be
able to get a pretty good flat screen TV for
about $500.
Without our reserve status, that TV might
cost hundreds, if not thousands more.
MALLABY: And then the other one is that the
United States gets to borrow more cheaply
from foreigners because there is this desire
to hold U.S. assets; foreigners are more willing
to lend money to the United States at lower
interest rates than they would demand otherwise,
because they're getting this sort of safety
advantage.
And so the United States can borrow more cheaply
from other countries.
It is, as the French president Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing once said, "an exorbitant privilege."
The risks in the privileges that if you ever
overuse it and borrow too much, you end up
with a national debt one day that proves very
difficult to sustain, but we haven't reached
that day yet.
SIERRA: One of the strangest parts of this
is that during times of tension, when most
countries and individuals would have a hard
time getting a loan, it becomes even easier
for the United States to do so.
MALLABY: When you are in a crisis, you want
to hold the safest asset and the dollar is
perceived as the safest asset.
And in some sense that perception is self-fulfilling.
People expect the dollar to retain its value
in a crisis.
And therefore, it does retain its value in
a crisis because money floods into dollar
assets as being safer than the alternatives.
SIERRA: So at times like 9/11 or the 2008
financial crisis, people are looking for dollars.
MALLABY: That's right.
And in fact, that leads to a sort of interesting
paradox, which says something about the nature
of U.S. power in the world.
You can have moments of geopolitical crisis,
like after 9/11, leading up to the preparations
for the Iraq war, where much of the world
is not supportive of U.S. policy; that was
true of the Iraq war, for example.
And they are voting against the United States
at the UN Security Council.
And yet at the same time, they are buying
U.S. dollars because that's a time of instability
and there's a flight to safety phenomenon
in currency markets.
So whilst opposing the U.S. policy in Iraq,
they are in a sense lending money to the United
States to go and conduct that conflict.
And so the United States gets to borrow even
from allies or other countries that are critical
of its policies.
Roger Ferguson was vice chairman of the Federal
Reserve on Sept 11th, and he had to deal with
this issue first hand.
FERGUSON: That was obviously a moment of phenomenal
tragedy in terms of loss of life in New York
and Washington and in a field in Pennsylvania.
It was also a time when the reserve currency
status in the United States was both a strength
and a problem.
It was a strength, because as always occurs
during a crisis, people tend to go to the
U.S. markets and in particular, the U.S. treasury
securities as the safe investment; so- called
Safe Haven.
What we did see, though, was the fact that
so many debts around the world are denominated
in dollars, and so much trade is denominated
in the dollars.
That we found many other central banks wanted
to come to us and have access to dollars.
And so we had to put in place what's called
a swap arrangement with the ECB and the Bank
of England, and we had to renew one with Canada.
And the same thing I believe has been happening
during the 2020 pandemic as well.
If you have a reserve currency during moments
of crisis, you may find your central bank
being called upon to be the global banker
and provide your currency through loans or
through swap arrangements, as they're called,
to others around the world.
SIERRA: As Roger noted a few minutes ago,
our reserve status doesn’t just let us support
allies in moments of crisis, it also lets
us impose painful sanctions on adversaries.
MALLABY: Because of the dollar’s incredibly
central role in global finance, global financial
institutions, even if they are, let's say
a Swiss bank, or a Japanese bank, they will
have an operation in the United States.
It's difficult to be a big international financial
institution and not operate in the United
States and not operate with dollars.
And that means that the United Stated has
leverage over pretty much every big financial
institution in the world.
And if it says, for example, financial institutions
should not lend to Iran or should not lend
to Russia, or should not facilitate trade
finance with Iran or Russia, or payments for
oil trade, or what have you.
It can pretty much freeze those pariah economies
out of global commerce and really exert powerful
sanctions, that would otherwise be difficult
to enforce.
So that is another aspect of U.S. power that
derives from the dollar status as a reserve
currency.
SIERRA: Our reserve status may be an “exorbitant
privilege”, as that former French president
said.
It makes foreign goods inexpensive,it allows
us to bounce back quickly in times of crisis,
and it empowers us to levy sanctions that
have serious consequences.
But there are some pretty important downsides
too.
MALLABY: The main disadvantage is sort of
linked to the advantage.
You know, a strong US dollar is nice for U.S.
consumers who get to buy foreign stuff more
cheaply, but not so nice for U.S. producers
that then have to sell their goods competing
against foreign countries, which have a sort
of cost advantage in production, if the U.S.
dollar is strong; that will hurt US exporters.
SIERRA: Here’s the flip side of that $500
TV.
If you want to start a business making TVs
in the United States, you are going to have
a rough time.
A strong dollar means that you will have to
compete with foreign goods and services that
are cheaper than they otherwise would be.
FERGUSON: It may well be that our ability
to run these deficits, very low interest rates,
has ultimately led to the fact that we are
now willing to import more goods in particular
from overseas.
Particularly from the Chinese, but not just
from the Chinese.
And some people say, well, gee, the lack of
manufacturing in the United States may be
due to the fact that it's been so easy for
us to import goods from other countries, and
that has created some imbalances in our own
economy.
SIERRA: So, what's the connection between
the dollar as reserve currency and our 23.3
trillion dollars in national debt?
FERGUSON: Well, the link is indirect, but
many people think it's quite real.
Treasury notes, treasury bills, treasury bonds
- those are all debts of the United States
government that we promise to pay back at
some point.
So, the concern is that the fact that we have
this ready supply of lenders, folks who have
dollars and want to lend it back to us, means
it's easier for us to run this deficit.
And the deficit has gotten larger and larger,
without actually having a big increase in
interest rates.
And this is pretty unusual.
And many people think it's the reserve currency
status that has allowed us to be, you know,
sort of profligate, borrowing more than we
should, living a little bit beyond our means,
perhaps.
Not taxing to pay for the things that the
U.S. government wants to spend on.
The concern is, obviously, over time, not
my generation, but other generations at some
point, will have to pay for this debt that's
outstanding.And that could have a pretty detrimental
impact on our own quality of life here in
the United States eventually.
SIERRA: From this perspective the United States
is a bit like a person with a very good credit
score who has a lot of credit card debt at
a very low interest rate.
Some economists feel that it has worked well
for many decades and will continue to do so.
Others tend to think a debt is a debt, and
that it will eventually hurt us to keep borrowing
so much money.
Amid this debate, there’s one country that
comes up time and again, China.
SIERRA: So, China owns more US debt than any
other country, right?
So, some people express a lot of alarm about
this.
What's the real story there?
FERGUSON: The real story is more complicated
than, I know.
It's a stunning thought that the story's more
complicated than the headlines.
So, the reason that China has come to have
so much of U.S. dollar - denominated securities,
particularly treasury bonds and bills, is
that their economy depends very much on exporting
goods to the United States.
And so, we are in what one might call a symbiotic
relationship.
Both sides sort of benefit from this relationship.
The Chinese have been able to build up their
economy, mainly through manufacturing, taking
many hundreds of millions, if not billions,
of Chinese out of abject poverty.
And the United States has been able to benefit,
if one thinks of that, by getting, you know,
relatively inexpensive, relatively high quality
goods made in China and paying for them with
dollars that we can print as many as we want,
and the Chinese are willing to hold them.
The other concern, by the way, is a fear that
at some point the Chinese, because we have,
again, a complex relationship with them, may
decide, well, we don't want to keep buying
all these government securities, this debt
that the United States is pumping out every
year.
And then, you know, there's some anxiety that
that will affect the market for U.S. treasury
securities.
And, you know, effectively, the concern is
that the Chinese can use their reserves in
a way that can be quite adversarial to U.S.
interests.
But people ignore that; if they were gonna
do that, the value of the debt that they themselves
hold, the Chinese hold, would go down, and
so they would suffer some of the pain as well.
________________
SIERRA: So when someone says China could call
in our debt tomorrow and ruin us, that doesn't
strike you as a particularly accurate way
of looking at it?
FERGUSON: It's not a completely accurate way
of looking at it because, you know, they are
holding a debt for their own good (laughs)
reasons.
Which is it allows them to maintain this export
oriented manufacturing sector that has been
so central to their financial success, and
economic success over the last thirty or forty
years.
SIERRA: Yes, we’ve grown dependent on China
buying our treasuries, but China also depends
on us to buy their goods.
It’s not a situation that either country
can pull out of without doing harm to itself.
But things do change with time.
For millennia, gold was the most reliable
currency across the world.
As empires came and went, so did their currencies.
If you asked a British citizen about the pound
in the 19th century, they might have thought
that it would remain the world’s currency
forever.
When we look to the future of reserve currencies,
do you think the dollar could ever lose ground
on its status?
FERGUSON: So, the answer is the dollar could
certainly lose ground on its status, the way
you phrase it.
In fact, we have over time lost ground.
Notice that I said that now about 60 percent
of foreign reserves are held in U.S. dollars.
Well, back in the 40s and the 50s, that number
was clearly much higher.
So the answer is, yes, we already have lost
some of our positioning as a reserve currency.And
I would expect over time that that was likely
to continue.
SIERRA: The United States is slowly losing
ground, but most economists think that its
position is likely to continue for the foreseeable
future.
Still, that hasn’t stopped many from speculating
about the potential for another currency to
displace the U.S. dollar.
And some of these theorists think that it
won’t be another national currency at all,
but rather cryptocurrency - digital assets
like Bitcoin.
Al Jazeera: It’s bitcoin season again; at
the time of the year when the world’s most
famous and least understood currency explodes
in value seemingly for no reasons at all.
CNN: The world’s richest man now investing
1.5 billion dollars worth of his company’s
money in the crypto currency.
Kitco News: A former Canadian prime minister
Steven Hart recently said that he sees a potential
for the crypto to become a reserve currency.
MALLABY: Yes.
Going back, there's been two kinds of money,
really.
There's been money created by national governments,
but there's also been commodities, notably
gold, a little bit silver.
And through history, there have been periods
when people have lost faith in governments
issuing money, and they've bought gold as
a protection against government-created currencies
going wrong.
Bitcoin is sort of the new version of that.
It's a non-government kind of currency.
The argument of the Bitcoin enthusiasts is
that it's not safe to keep your money in dollars
because there might be inflation and you never
know the dollar might be devalued by inflation.
Therefore, you want some alternative asset
that is absolutely going to retain its value.
And they say, well, Bitcoin could be that
asset because it's supply is algorithmically
capped.
You can't have more than a certain amount
of Bitcoin, and therefore you can't print
tons of it and destroy its value.
Now, for various reasons, this Bitcoin proposition
doesn't quite convince everybody, not least
me.
I'm trying to be tactful about this.
You know, if you're trying to argue that the
dollar's value might be unstable and you're
saying, well, Bitcoin is better.
The fact that you've had these incredible
bubbles and crashes in Bitcoin in the last
five years is not encouraging to that thesis.
And although the supply of Bitcoin is algorithmically
capped, most algorithmic systems have been
susceptible to hacking in the past.
And I'm not sure that I trust some anonymously
created code more than I trust the Federal
Reserve Bank of the United States.
Most of the enthusiasm for Bitcoin is people
who just basically don't trust the government.
But there could be another type of enthusiasm,
which is people who don't like the U.S. dominance
of the system.
They're more about being anti-American than
being anti-government.So, that sort of resentment
of the dollar, which you see today in countries
like Russia, which are the object of U.S.
sanctions, and those sanctions are very much
made more powerful by the dollar’s global
status.
You see pushes to create alternatives to the
dollar from countries that don't like U.S.
power, and indeed, the Chinese efforts to
advance the renminbi as an international currency
are very much linked to a sense that the United
States just has too much power in the system
because of the dollar status as the global
reserves currency.
SIERRA: Which brings us to the other currency
that some think could eventually eclipse the
dollar: the Chinese Renminbi.
MALLABY: In order to have a reserve currency,
one thing you've got to provide is the ability
for foreigners to easily buy bonds in your
currency, and to feel confident that having
bought those bonds, they can sell them and
get a fair price for them.
And they won't be subject to all kinds of
restraints and controls.
And China's capital markets simply are not
free enough and open enough yet for that to
be the case.
It is moving in that direction in the last
few years; China has gone quite a way to creating
an impressive, corporate bond market, for
example.
And that's a step in the direction of having
a credible claim on being a reserve currency,
but there is quite a long road for China to
go.
FERGUSON: It is certainly true that the Chinese,
I think, would like to see their currency,
the renminbi, become a larger currency in
terms of its holdings as a reserve currency
around the world.
I think that for them creates a sense of belonging
in the international community, and frankly,
a sense of prestige.
After all, they are by many measures the second
largest economy in the world.
And so there is, I think, bragging rights
as far as they're concerned.
I think, more importantly, the real question
is whether or not, you know, trading partners,
others believe that it's very important to
maintain, you know, good relationships with
China and whether or not they see that as
being a question of maintaining relationships
with China versus the United States, or China
in addition to the United States.
And so I think this whole issue of reserve
currency status is a little bit in the eyes
of the Chinese, a sign of prestige, and it's
a sign of being respected as an important
part of the global system.
From the standpoint of the United States,
I think, we would very much like to understand
how China wants to participate in the global
economy.
And I would observe that we want to make sure
that they want to participate in a way that's
respectful of the values of others, respectful,
frankly, of democracy.
SIERRA: China certainly has the economic heft
to challenge the United States on reserve
currency status, but it may lack some of the
other elements that lead to trust in a currency.
One problem is that as an authoritarian nation,
China doesn’t always play by the same rules
as the Western world.
China has been accused of dumping products,
manipulating the value of its currency, and
exerting strict controls over foreign investments.
Taken together, these factors make investors
worry that Beijing will prioritize its own
goals over the safety of their investment.
So Do you think that the power of our reserve
status comes with a sort of, you know, global
responsibility?
I guess what I'm trying to ask is whether
it makes us a kind of caretaker for the global
economy.
MALLABY: Yes, we are.
The Federal Reserve proved after 2008 how
important it was to stabilize not just the
U.S. financial system, but other countries
as well, because those other countries use
dollars so much.
It's important that the Federal Reserve be
ready to provide emergency infusions of dollars
when they're needed.
And that's what the Fed did, with its so-called
swap lines in 2009.
And that readiness is an aspect of sort of
the U.S. continued guardianship of the global
system.
FERGUSON: So, you know, there are people who
think we have the obligation, because we have
a reserve currency, to be a bit of a caretaker
for the global economy.
My view is the most important thing we can
do for the global economy is to make sure
that our economy is functioning smoothly,
that we keep inflation under control, that
we grow our potential, that we maintain maximum
employment.
That is, I think, the ultimate obligation
that we have here in the United States, and
then everything else will, I think, fall into
place over time.
SIERRA: So last question, and it's a little
bit of a toughie, but as a normal person,
just going about minding my own business and
trying to make it in the world today, how
does the dollar as a reserve affect my life?
MALLABY: For a regular U.S. citizen, the U.S.
dollar status as a reserve currency means
one thing for you, which is the dollars that
you earn are more valuable in the world, and
you can buy more foreign staff and go on more
foreign vacations.
And secondly, it means that your country is
more secure and more powerful because that
dollar status means that in a crunch, the
United States can borrow the money it needs.
It means that in a geopolitical standoff,
the United States can impose sanctions on
other countries and they will have more force.
And just the sheer importance of the dollar
in the global system gives the United States
diplomatic clout that is of valuable asset
for the nation.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hey?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And, please please, if you are a fan of the
show, show us some love!
Give us five stars and leave a review on Apple
Podcasts.
It means so much to us, and it really does
help us to get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Our intern for this semester is Zoe Han.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Additional research and extra help were provided
by Elena Tchainikova and James McBride.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!